Hey, what's going on is bill burn
his time for the Thursday afternoon?
Just before Friday. Monday
morning podcast. Dan,
just checking in on you. Oh, I
almost passed out doing that.
I'm just checking in or just seeing how
your week's going. How's it going, man?
You're almost there. You're almost
there. You're almost to the weekend.
It's going to be your world again.
You're gonna get to do site.
Decide when you wake up.
Do side no d side.
I said greatest fucking thing about
Saturday morning. You decide all right,
and I don't care if you got kids.
I don't care if you've got a wife,
you've got a husband and this Dan,
I hear you guys.
I need you to shut the fuck up.
You're not the boss of me.
It's Saturday.
I'm staying in this fucking bed.
Hey, the kid's crying, sweetheart.
I am crying. What did they cry? They
didn't want to fuck. They're crying about,
oh they downstairs. You know what?
What? What are they doing right now?
What are they crying about?
What toy does somebody want
that somebody else he had this.
That's not a life or death situation.
I am going to lay in this fucking bed
and I want to get up when I decided
that's what Saturday's all about
Santa,
that feeling you have on Saturday morning
when you can basically do whatever the
fuck it is you want, provided the
woman in your life is afraid of you
joking.
You can do whatever it is the
fuck you want to do. All right.
That feeling right there,
that's the feeling that you
should be working towards.
Okay. That misery, that
Monday through Friday awaken,
I got away. Glad I got to wake
up cause I have, cause I fucking,
I get an agreement with these people down
the street that I have to be there and
they have to be able to see my face at
this particular fucking time and I got to
trudge in here and do this fucking job.
However,
once you get to feel what it's
like to be living your dream
acquaintance, you gotta
be thinking, what bill?
I can't fucking lay in a bed a whole
fucking, you know, Monday through Sunday.
How would I eat?
How would I eat that?
Right there is what
handouts or for it's what?
Seven 11 to four you want to sleep
in every day? This is what you do.
You sit outside is seven 11 you
make a little sign. All right.
You don't write it on a nice
piece of notebook paper.
You got to write it on like a piece of
trash you so people know that you're
struggling right now. I'm fucking
with you. Somehow you got,
you got to become self employed.
You got to work for yourself if
you want that Saturday morning.
Granted you're going to still be working
on only you get to work Monday through
Friday when you're self employed,
you work Monday through Sunday,
but you'll get up when you want to get up.
All right?
And you at least have that feeling of
a little bit of control and freedom.
Then he can take it too far. Like the
ultimate Saturday I'll get up when the,
wherever the fuck I want to is that
fatty cakes there in North Korea.
Okay. And you can tell by his build that
Guy Sleeps Til at least 11 every day,
you know? I bet he has like kid pajamas.
Does he look like he would, you know,
giant speed racer bed or some shit.
Something about him.
He seems very childish,
you know.
I Dunno. You know what it
is. I bet he just, because he
was the, the dictators son,
nobody ever picked on it, but he
looked in the mirror and he was like,
the only reason why they're not
picking on me right now is because
if they did, my dad would feed
them naked to two wild dogs.
That's the only thing
stopping the Calafat. I am,
look at me just standing there
looking at his hair. Hairy,
hairless fucking tore self. Right. I
bet he's getting any right. Some man,
whole fucking level.
Any,
there's some whole enemies
trying to fill. Um, anyways,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking
about. How about those Cleveland?
God Damn Indians. 21 victories in a
row. You're never going see this again.
I mean it's fucking amazing.
That is really amazing. Um,
and how great would it be to
see them and they're ones,
was it 1948 they ended it this year?
I Dunno about my red sox.
I don't know.
I'm going to keep saying that hope
and I jinx them into coming together.
I kind of fucking fell out
of love with this team.
I've said it before when they fucking
yelled at Eckersley I was like, come on.
There was no discipline about,
that's a hall of Famer.
You know what you're doing in a
hall of famer walks in a room.
You shut the fuck up.
That's what you do.
And if he criticizes you,
you say, okay, fair enough.
I'll try a little better. Their
sport maybe asked for exotic now.
Now you don't ask for his autograph. You
want to be a professional. If you want,
if you want to act like you're,
you're, you're in the same business.
You never asked for an autograph within
the same industry. Okay? None of it.
Forget that. I've seen people do it.
It's an ugly, ugly fucking scene.
I know a guy that fucking play golf
and a celebrity fucking tournament,
right? Why can't I ever
type in my password and talk
at the same fucking time?
It's unbelievable.
He played in a celebrity golf tournament
and one of the guys in his fourth son
was actually a fan of his and then
fucking hanging out the palling around.
Everything's going great.
And then when that,
when they would done at
the end of the round,
he asked for a picture in the guy's
face just dropped. And that was it.
It was over. He went from hanging out
with that guy to be in back in the crowd,
thrown his panties out
of what is my point?
My point is I like sleeping in on us.
Um,
all right.
Let's see what's,
I don't have anything to talk about
today because I'm just stuck in a fucking
writer's room. We just, we're doing the
table read this morning for episode, uh,
three Oh seven. Oh I can't be screaming
at, my daughter's still sleeping. My mom,
my wife's probably going to
fucking kill me right now on say,
is there a reason why
ever since Bill Clinton,
they just won't let somebody be president?
I really think you know what it is.
I think it's because of,
I think it's because of social media and
24 hours news networks and all of that
type of shit.
Yeah.
This is like CNN,
CNN who refuses to cover any,
anything about Hillary
and the Democratic Party,
ignoring the votes during the primary and
boxing out Bernie Sanders who actually
gotten more votes.
And then Hillary actually has the fucking
balls to be like we should do away
with the electoral college.
Oh,
because the fuck over that you ran on
Bernie Sanders then was done to you.
I've never seen such an
entitled fucking person.
Everybody talks about
how entitled Trump is,
and I'm not saying he
isn't Jesus fucking Christ.
She really thought that that job was hers.
It's fucking unbelievable.
Anyways.
Um,
okay.
It's unfucking believable. Um, all right.
It says Sean Spicer basically admitted
that he was willing to lie for Trump.
Now,
what is shocking about that?
Okay.
Do you think there was nobody in Obama's
cabinet that was willing to lie for him
or bushes or Clinton's or
first Bush or Reagan or Carter?
That's what happens.
Yeah.
Think about in your life,
there's people you're willing to lie for.
Yeah.
You know, your buddy's fucking hammered
behind the wheel. The cop comes up,
you sit down, officer, he's, oh, he's
fine. He's only had a couple of, you know,
you do that.
It's a friend,
Jesus fucking Christ and everybody
fucking sitting here acting like the
president runs the country
is fucking hilarious.
Like he's decisions aren't decided
pie all the money that you fucking need
to get in the fucking office. Right.
I don't know. They keep saying Trump
used most of his own money. I doubt it.
I don't fucking, I don't even know
what the fuck I'm talking about.
I'm just so fucking sick of people.
You know,
acting like this guy is way worse than
the other guy because the two or three
issues other than that,
as far as the environment,
as far as the food supply,
as far as the heroin epidemic,
it's the exact same thing. Don't
fucking say shit about it. Right.
Is that what it is? I Dunno.
All right. After Chicago, Tj,
ginger is found dead in a,
in hotel freezer.
Mystery lingers.
This is why I don't want you to know
North Korea's latest nuclear tests so
powerful.
It reshaped the mountain above it.
Okay?
Okay. Well, we have its nuclear
power. It's powerful. Rush your fires.
Cruise missile at ISPD stronghold.
Is that the cool way to say Isis
now is I a stronghold in East Syria?
Russia is about to kick off a war
game that is freaking out. NATO.
Here's what we know. This is why I
don't read the news. I wouldn't know.
I wouldn't know any of this.
It's a game having a game.
They can't play a game
in their own country.
Coordinated attack in southern
Iraq kills at least 50
okay?
Okay. No good news yet. All right,
let's go to the United States.
Let's see what good news is here. Eight
dead after South Florida nursing homes,
air conditioning fails
following Hurricane Irma.
Great.
Next one as the White
House calls for her firing.
Okay.
Espn Jamelle Hill.
Address the elephant in the room.
Okay.
What the fuck is this?
How the fuck did we go from the White
House to a reporter on ESPN? Now this,
now this, I'll tell you. Let's here.
I gotta read this one. I got to read.
All right,
here we go. Here we go. What did we say?
How's hours after a White House
spokesperson called for Espn to fire her?
Because she called president Trump
a white supremacist on Twitter.
Jamil Hill or Jamelle modal.
He'll tweeted about the topic Wednesday
night saying she was going to address
the elephant in the room after becoming
the latest flash point in a cultural
skirmish that is involved. The
sports network. Once again,
hashtagging your tweets.
Hashtag facts hill wrote my comments
on Twitter express my personal belief,
my regard,
my regret is that my comments at and the
public way I made them painted ESPN in
an unfair light.
My respect for the company and my
colleagues remains unconditional. Yeah.
How the fuck do you have that job? And
No, you can't tweet some shit like that.
You're going to get fired
because at the end of the day,
all ESPN gives a fuck about
is ratings in, in, in money.
That's what they care
about. Uh, all right,
so when asked Wednesday
afternoon by the Post,
David knock a mirror lockup Moreau.
It's a good last name.
Uh,
about hills original tweets.
Sarah Huckabee Sanders said she was
unsure whether the president was aware of
the kerfuffle they cause, but
at, of course he was aware. Okay.
Fucking tweets every day.
It's like a seventh grade girl.
I think that's one of the more outrageous
comments that anyone could make and
certainly something that I think
is fireable offense by ESPN.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Okay.
Oh,
give me a fucking break.
I love how ESPN thinks that
reflects on them and all they is.
A couple of [inaudible]
Iran may have, you know, further
woo at the bottom are prevalent. Oh,
ain't gonna walk to see if the Yankees
beat the fucking Indians tonight.
Okay.
Yes you are.
What else are you going to do?
Read a book.
It's his sports network.
This is some of the dumbest people
on the planet, myself included.
Okay.
You how many times I've tried,
I've gotten so disgusted with the NFL.
I tried to walk away. Then I just had
to admit that I was too weak to do it.
I like how the NFL ratings are down now
and they're trying to blame that stupid
Colin Kaepernick thing. That's what it
was. Oh, that's what it Wa wasn't what,
you know what it was is they just got
greedy. I think it's the NFL plus it,
it goes in cycles too.
You know what I mean?
It's like the NBA where they
had bird magic into fucking, uh,
Jordan and then there was a little bit
of a lull there for a minute. Right.
And then like a,
I dunno.
Okay.
I guess the spurs more fucking
exciting enough. Um, I dunno.
And then you know, eventually you other
guys came along, the Brown came along.
Yeah, the next one. Right. I think
football goes to the same thing,
but the problem is that these,
these, these guys in the NFL,
they're trying to go global and
they're trying to appeal like please,
as many people as humanly possible.
So they kind of abandoned
their original fit in the end.
You know where the NBA is right now.
The NBA is where you two was when Bano
started wearing those big fly glasses,
the big mosquito glasses
and was saying shit like this is the
most surreal night of my life, man.
He started playing a character,
you know,
in eight years they went from
carrying a fucking white flag and all,
whatever the fuck it is
they were doing back then.
I was never the big youtube
guy. Okay. As I told you before,
I didn't listen to the
right music in the 80s.
I was listening to a crocus and helix,
how's this and all those fucking beds,
you know what I mean?
And then I was watching sports and I was
flunking math and French class. I mean,
that's basically what you've been
listening to all these years.
If you ever wondered,
um,
I don't need to go to ancestry.com
to figure out my mystery.
I am a fucking dope.
I am a dope dope when I walk into a room,
dopes shut up just to listen to
what stupid thing I'm gonna say.
Um, anyways. Yeah. They fucking,
they, they did the pink thing. Let's
have the football players wear pink.
I love how,
like for some reason the fact that a
football is a really male testosterone
aggressive thing that like for some
reason guys have to apologize for that and
they just can't have,
is that the word of feminate?
They can't make it like,
like feminine enough all of a sudden
cause all these feminist bitch
moaning and complaining has all these
corporations all in a myth like,
oh we don't want to be considered sexist.
The next thing you know,
they're wearing pink for a month.
It's if the NFL gives a flying fuck
okay.
About anything other than making money.
Cancer.
This is what we care about. Your brain
Terman into scrambled eggs. Yeah.
We don't get in. You killing
yourself by the time you're 50.
We don't give a fuck about
that. Oh, is that what you did?
Here's 40 bucks for everybody
who ever played the fucking game.
They don't give a shit.
Um, according to reports,
they kept like 95 to $97 for every hundred
dollars he made off of that pink shit.
So give me a fucking break.
They show people in the crowd
that are in the military,
they charge that branch of the military.
They treat it like a commercial as
they tell you to support the troops.
The Fuck Outta here. Right? So now what?
So now all these women's groups sit
there bitch moaning and complaining.
So now they got, they got female referees,
they get women calling the games.
They got the guys wearing pink
for an entire fucking month.
They got lady Gaga singing at the
fucking halftime at the super bowl.
They took a total fucking left turn.
And when you do that like you to do
is you're going to lose a lot of your
original fan base that are like,
hey man,
I liked him back when the
boy I liked the first album.
I saw him when there was only
8,000 people at the fucking show.
That's basically what they're
going through and they're
going to survive it and
they're going to transition from,
you know,
the frozen Tundra and all of that fucking,
making it seem like it was fucking d day.
All of that great shit that I loved.
They are going to transition
out of all of that and
I think that there's going
to be a lot more futures in,
in teals and all that type of stuff
coming into the NFL is they try to,
uh,
okay.
I Dunno.
I think I say try to get ahead of this
next generation of people that that's
coming up that goes out to comedy
clubs and literally just stares at the
comedians.
Like that's what I'm experiencing now.
I was at the comedy store last night.
Granted something fucked up
happened before I went on stage.
I guess it should have realized
that. And uh, they, yeah, just uh,
just staring at me
staring at me.
So I dunno. I Dunno what I have
to do. You know what I'm thinking?
Actually maybe I'll,
I'll start wearing pink on stage and
then people will think that I care.
Um, anyways, I don't want
to, I don't want to fucking,
I don't want to call out any
fucking specific fucking people.
I don't want to fucking do that cause
you know, I sucked as a comedian.
Eventually I got better at it,
but I mean, Jesus fucking Christ,
if you're going to go down that road,
you still have to pick somebody
that's of a fucking certain level of
professionalism. Now, if you're going
to have a fucking national game,
yeah,
I mean Jesus Christ,
and I'm not talking about that poor
bastard that froze like a deer in a
headlight. That fucking kid on the side
too. I just felt bad for that dude.
You know what I mean? But
I'm just saying, you know,
if you're going to call a fucking game,
good fuck it,
Lord. Good Lord. Um,
this is actually my dream.
My dream is somebody that like is like a
fucking went to broadcasting school and
then you pair them up with
someone that played the game.
I know they tried to do that all the time,
but someone that actually can tell a
story that played the fucking gate,
that's when it's the best. Like
Collins worth, John Madden,
Phil, I love a lot of people. Didn't
like Phil soon. I love Phil Simms,
the Guy Fucking, you won a super
bowl. He's the first guy to say,
I'm going to Disneyland.
I'm not going to listen to this guy.
All these guys who play fantasy football
trying to say the guy doesn't know what
he's talking about. Yeah. What? What
would he know about what? You know?
He only played the game professionally.
You fucking moron.
MMM.
I Dunno.
Okay.
Wait a second.
What the fuck is going on here?
All right. I don't know what the Hell I
just did. I had my recorder on the floor.
I don't know when the hell
I just chopped it off,
but I had the thing
recording on the wrong speed.
I Dunno what the fuck happened anyways.
I don't fuck,
I don't know what's going on and
what's going on in comedy clubs.
I don't know what's going
on and a in the NFL,
I don't know what the fuck
they're doing and this is just,
it's just part of becoming old.
Okay.
Like why did I got a partner
of street lights up so bright?
Like I'm just an old man.
Don't fucking listen to me.
Okay.
Anyways,
I don't understand how I had a half hour
to do this before nine o'clock and it's
almost nine o'clock and I only have
fucking 20 minutes done probably because I
stepped on the recorder and
I said the fucking worst.
I'm the worst anyways.
So congratulations to the NFL.
I know you guys want to go global.
I hope you fucking do it. Um,
you know,
I'm sure you're jealous of the UFC that
started way after you guys and they were
able to do it.
You are free.
MMM.
You know,
I don't know what the fuck to tell you.
Okay.
I Dunno what the fuck to tell you.
It's just like, I don't, I, uh,
I kinda like college football.
My start watching that and then eventually
they're going to get pressure to
fucking make this game a male
testosterone game for some reason.
We need a bunch of estrogen in it.
Yeah.
You know, this is what I don't
understand about women. Okay.
Every study says that they're
way smarter than men. Right.
They can handle a stronger level of pain.
Okay.
They're more in touch with their emotions.
They could do all of that shit and you
know, for them, far as my experience goes,
I'd agree with it for the most part.
Yeah.
I don't know about the arrogant.
We're smarter than you.
It depends on what the fuck you talking
about. Right? But I'll give you,
I'll give you all of that.
But if that's all true,
what if fuck kitchen starts your own
sports league? Why don't you do that?
Okay.
What do you constantly have to
fucking infiltrate some shit?
A bunch of guys doing some shit that you
know at the end of the day you think is
fucking stupid. It's a bunch of guys
smashing into each other's scrambling.
They're fucking brains trying to get a
ball crossed the fucking line to score
points. You know, you don't
give a shit about that.
Why can't they come up with their own
Goddamn fucking sports league and then
from top to bottom,
fucking can be all women.
Then you turn that thing into a
global billion dollar fucking entity.
And then women get all that fucking money.
There's your power.
You'll fucking join a guy's league.
And then they give you a pink flags
to throw holding office. It's like,
why would you do that? I don't
know. I don't fucking know.
I don't know.
I don't understand these things.
Yeah.
All I can, all I can do is we equate
it to my life as I can tell you this,
when I worked for somebody else,
I like the fuck over is you
can't, you can't keep up.
You can't keep track of him.
Okay?
That's when you get stolen from the most.
That's when your dream
gets crushed the most.
When you fucking work for somebody else,
if you work for yourself,
you have more control. Granted,
you work way more hours,
but that's the price you pay. We're
taking collars. Um, all right.
Let me read a little bit of advertising
here. Everybody. Um, by the way,
a fucking oh Billy, no
fun, no booze. 28 days,
28 days a week.
I don't fucking booze.
I stare at the ceiling
trying to go to sleep. Ooh,
I love that whiskey.
It's my Tylenol pm. Um,
speaking of which, this is going to
be the biggest test for my air quotes.
Sobriety. I'm not fucking sober. I'm
just not drinking. Okay. All right.
This is the biggest test.
Saucy thought.
The Miyao guys saucy.
Everyone at some point has
wished they could just have beer,
wine or liquor delivered.
Will someone filing decided to
do something about it? Oh my God,
I love these people. Next, please mention
all the talking points below. Dude,
I'll fucking sing these if you want to.
Want me to.
Introducing thought the meow,
the alcohol delivering app.
Southie are our delivers your favorite
wine and beer and liquor right to your
door on demand.
It's Uber for alcohol.
This is great. This is
fucking great. Uber's great,
right? I should say lift cause they
fucking advertise on us, right?
Oh I love those. Those, those guys
at Lyft and the ladies, right?
They fucking uh,
you know,
they cut down on drinking and driving
right now they're going to cut down on
fucking ruin in the ozone layer. Might
get some stores to drive liquor store,
drive it over to you, whatever. All he
knows you're not in the street, dude.
You turn your fucking apartment
into the club. You never leave.
They never shut you off.
This is great. Okay. Now,
if you're in Los Angeles, San
Francisco, Chicago, San Diego, away,
whale's Vagina or Sacramento,
you're thought the order will arrive
at your door in 30 minutes or less.
Ready to drink. All right
guys. Now La, San Francisco,
Chicago, San Diego, Sacramento.
You got to fucking drink up.
You got to get these people the money
that they need to expand. All right,
for the right. This is like the original
sex except as five cities first, okay?
For the rest of us thought
the will deliver beer, wine,
and liquor to your door in
two days or less. Nationwide.
There are no minimums, no order
minimums, no delivery fees,
no running to the store.
If you've got the saucy app around,
you've got a fully stocked bar on
your phone and for a limited time,
dude,
you can start drinking top shelf booze
now cause you're not going out playing in
a cover and or any of that
type of shit, okay? You go out,
you fucking rub one out at home. Okay. You
just hand no, no, my hitting on checks.
Right.
And maybe buy that fucking robot doll
that came out last year for 10 grand that
you can bank that eventually Joe Rogan
was tweeting that you can fucking hackers
can hack into it and teach it to kill
you. It's really scary days coming up. Um,
anyways and for a limited time you
can get $15 off your download when you
download the thoughts,
the APP and enter Promo Code Bird that's
saucy me how app spelled s a u c e y
honey and enter Promo code
[inaudible] for $15 off.
Gets the saucy app today
and use Promo Code.
Burn a write draft kings everybody.
Week one is in the books but it's,
it's not too late to
get closer to the game.
You love car crawl right up the ass crack
of the NFL with draft kings one week
fantasy football.
This Sunday draft kings is hosting
a $100,000 degenerate gambler.
Pick him contest that is
totally free to enter.
Pick them is the newest way to play.
One week fantasy football.
Drafting your team as a
fee is faster than ever.
Draft Kings has organized
players into eight tiers.
All you have to do is select
one player from each tier.
Choose between the public,
uh,
choose between public contests with big
cash prizes or private contests where
you can compete against
a group of your friends.
Draft kings also has beginner and casual
contests where you play against people
of a similar skill level.
The best part is you get to draft a new
team each week without any commitment.
So get draftkings.com now and use Promo
Code Burr to play and draftkings free
contest with a $100,000 drought.
Talk dollars in total prices this Sunday.
Use My Promo Code Burford to
play for free this Sunday.
That's Promo Code [inaudible]
at draftkings.com eligibility
restrictions apply.
See draft kings.com for
details. Oh, look who's back.
Everybody simply thought they,
the average property loss from chest
one home breaking is too fucking grant
$2,316.
Jesus,
these people did their homework or they
made up a really great fake number.
If you tally all the
burglaries in your country,
the total loss is in the billions.
Simply safe home security protects
every door and window in your home,
but not the skylight. That's a window.
Yes. Right. Okay. Home secure. Okay.
You get motion sensors,
entry sensors.
Tom Cruise couldn't fucking
break into this place.
Simply safe system is completely wireless.
You can set it up
yourself with simply safe.
There's no longterm contracts or
hidden fees and you have professional,
a professional alarm monitoring
your place around the clock,
ready to send the police. That's just
15 bucks a month. Come on people.
Go to simply say bird.com and
get a special 10% discount
when you order today or
if you want this secure security system
right away, visit your local best.
Buy that simply safe bird.com for
10% off simply safe birth.com.
All right, two more. Hang in there.
Hang in there. Dollar Shave Club,
dude.
When you might not know,
what you might not know is that dollar
shave club also has products for pretty
much everything else you need in the
bathroom. Bodywash, Shampoo, hair, Gel,
lip balm, everything I've been to
bodywash or shampoo, hair, Gel,
lip balm at the store.
There are too many options.
I can't figure it out and you can't
tell the difference between any of them.
How dumb are you?
Then if you have any questions to clerk
usually doesn't know the difference or
there's just one fucking person work in
their cvs or can't really help you sense
they are not experts on the products.
College dropouts,
dollar Shave Club makes it
easy and convenient for you
to upgrade your shave and
your bathroom.
Now you don't have to step foot in a
store and get a hike to get a high quality
sh. I kept what happened?
I can't read anymore.
Now you don't have to step foot in a
store to get a high quality shave and
grooming products. Dollar Shave Club's
delivers them right to your fucking door.
They'd go in there and they're high
fiving the people that thought the me out,
just like a red,
their razors.
Everything is super high quality and we'll
leave you looking and feeling amazing
if you're sick of nonsense of
the nonsense. At the store.
Now's the time to try out dollar
shave club for a limited time.
Dollar Shave Club is basically
giving away. There's shit shower,
shave starter kit to
new members for only $5.
This start is set features, the
executive razor and three trial versions,
three trial size versions of the most
popular products that help you stay fresh
and clean, um, so fresh and so clean.
If your first box in your first box,
you will receive their shave butter,
bodywash and one wipe Charlies.
Oh chary but wipes.
Um,
you will also receive the executive
razor which includes their premium,
weighty handle and full
cassette of cartridges.
After the first box replacement cartridges
are sent for only a few bucks a month.
This offers exclusively
available@dollarshaveclub.com slash spur.
That's dollar shave club.com/bar hey,
dollar shave club's high quality products
have you covered from face cheeks to
butt cheeks.
There is no better time to try the club.
Oh look who's here. Have you buddy. Oh
Jesus. Here we go. Dodo. Dodo me undies,
me undies. What happened to the
NFL? Doo doot doot me undies,
me undies.
I think it's going to the hell.
Why'd he got to please everybody just
have people smashing into each other.
Who Cares?
Why do you have to have a bunch of pink,
a bunch of fucking ladies there?
You know it's a guy sport
because we won a theme.
Progressive.
Alright me undies.
Um, hey. If you send a feminist,
a dick pic that it has that,
but you have it in a little pink sweater.
Is that okay?
Is that considered a progressive?
I don't know. All right.
[inaudible] you want to look good
in your underwear, don't you?
You want to be comfortable,
right?
But that perfect balance is hard to find.
Don't sacrifice style or comfort.
Checkout me undies.com and find the best
pair of underwear in the world world.
Talk about why me undies is the
best underwear you'll ever own.
You know what I love about it?
They send it to me too for free.
It's nice and snug up against my nuts.
You know what I mean?
But it's affectionate. It's not suffocate.
Makes my nuts feel safe. And you know,
I gotta be honest with you, before I
met me undies, I never felt that before.
I want to
be.
And these will be the most comfortable
pair of underwear you will own made from
a sustainably sourced naturally soft
fabric that's three times softer than
cotton.
Right now me undies has an executive,
has an exclusive offer
for just my listeners.
Get 20% off your first pair and free
shipping and me undies is so sure you will
love their underwear. They even
offer a 100% satisfaction guarantee.
You order a pair and if you don't love
your first pair of get the get a full
refund,
this is a no brainer to try 20% off
free shipping and 100% satisfaction
guarantee.
What in the fuck are you waiting for to
get you 20% off free shipping and their
100% satisfaction guarantee and get the
best and softest underwear you will ever
own. Go to [inaudible] dot com slash
bird this is a limited time offer.
So what are you waiting for? Start
wearing the best underwear of your life.
It changed my life every
dentally according to the copy.
It's time to let me unease change yours.
Go to [inaudible] dot com
slash burr right now. Okay.
That's the podcast I got to go do the
table read for episode three Oh seven,
which means season three, episode
seven, which I never understood.
I used to be like, well, we're not
on episode 300 and stubborn. Um,
oh great computer falls to the floor.
That just probably woke up.
My daughter is there. My
daughter down there. I'm sorry.
This thing was so rushed and jumbled up.
Um,
but I'm under a time fucking thing here,
so I'm not gonna keep babbling about it.
Enjoy the music and a half hour of
greatest hits from a Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday. Monday morning podcast
from a Thursday. Gone by in a year.
Gone past or maybe it's from
earlier this year. I don't know.
Stone
stop
acquiring
going the box.
Ooh.
Frank Sinatra.
Oh,
by the way,
by the way. So I'm all over the fucking
map here. Did you fucking see that?
Shameless fucking Hillary Clinton?
Yeah.
Trying to pander to get the African
American vote. She's on some radio show.
I just watched a clip. I had
to shut it off. Forgive me.
I don't know what radio show it is,
but she's sitting there.
She goes and she's trying to
get the black vote and she,
they asked you what's something that
you always carry around with you?
And she said,
hot sauce.
What I found the Clintons are the fucking,
I swear to God.
Okay.
Can't you just see both of them on a
used car lot to one of those cheesy local
commercials?
Do they had the fucking devil?
Okay.
I remember when Hillary
Clinton ran for fucking, uh,
Senate after eight years of being in the
White House to fucking Yankees had won
four world series. She never showed
up, never said a fucking thing.
And then all of a sudden she's running
for fucking a Senate in New York,
shows up with a brand new Yaggie hat goes.
I've always been a Yankee fan.
And then this big grand,
like I said it now, they got to like
me. This is how out of touch she is.
She literally thinks that. She just
has to say, I carry around hot sauce
and I'll, all black people are going to be
like, oh shit. Oh, I can relate to that.
What's she gonna do next?
You get to go to fucking Chinatown,
which I always carry around soy sauce.
We go down south, you know, I
love guns and my cousins, sorry,
sorry, I shouldn't have
said that. Um, hot rods.
I've always liked hot rods.
Fucking shameless.
This is the thing about like when
you're at her level of fucking wealth,
which is really, I don't know how you
explain it. You know, when her husband,
you know,
had the highest office in,
in public office and you
only is president, you only
make four, 500 grand a year.
Somehow they threw their daughter
a $3 million wedding. I mean,
how does the math work there?
Okay.
They are the fucking, she is the fucking
devil. I'm telling you. You know.
Oh my God, what a fucking selection this
year. Can you fucking believe this shit?
A reality show star.
Okay.
You know who's sitting
there with that fucking,
I don't know what the other guy's name is.
Nick talking about the size of their
hands and having a good size of your dick
debate running for office.
You got Hillary.
You fucking write it. I'll say
it. She doesn't give a fuck.
This is why I gotta be honest with you.
Why I like Republicans better than
Democrats because the Republicans at least
have the decency to just show,
to openly show you that they don't
give a fuck about you and Democrats.
They actually tried to act like
they give a fuck how people thought.
People who work for a fucking living,
they don't did the same fucking people.
They just lie about it.
You know? I swear to God,
if Bernie Sanders would just
fucking gold the hallway,
you know what I mean?
Don't stop in Kuwait.
You got to go all the way to Baghdad
with these fucking bankers. Okay?
That's what you gotta do.
You gotta tip over the statue when you
got to have all those top level bankers
swinging at the end of a rope.
That's the only way to stay.
Got To start over again.
That's my candidate. None of them
are saying that. So it, it's over.
And I know you're thinking,
Bill, you don't know shit.
And you read conspiracy theory
and you know what I say to that?
You're absolutely right. Okay.
All right, let's move on.
That was, uh, that was, uh, that was
political comedy right there, if you will,
if you're wondering what that was
supposed to be, she goes to little Italy.
What do you always have in your purse?
A jar of Marinara sauce.
Who's your favorite singer?
Dean Martin.
Oh my God. Did you see the house?
She looked like she rolled her eyes.
I don't want to put like shit on her that,
that's what she fucking did.
Okay.
That's how out of touch she is.
Hillary Clinton thinks black.
All black people walk around with hot
sauce in their purse because white don't
know how to season food.
Uh,
I'm not saying there aren't some black
people did do that. You know what I mean?
But you know, that would also
be people who aren't white,
who look at white people and think we're
all in the upper 1% standing on a yard
shooting the shit with one
of the Kennedy's and they're
fucking weird in Brenton
inbred dentition. I never
understood the Kennedys. I, they,
they're from like the nose up. They're
really good looking people, great hair,
you know, nice fucking
big five head, you know,
it looks great on TV, decent eyes, you
know, and then you just get to that,
you get to those, those, I
mean it was kid. No, they
look like from the nose down,
they look like Clint Howard.
I don't know what it is.
There's something going on with
that family. You can't, uh,
you know what it is, is they still
look ethnic. They feel, look at, um,
if you look at like,
like white people from like,
like look at Joe Dimaggio, you know, he's
probably considered a good looking guy.
That guy is fucking deck.
Okay.
I don't know what happened once
everybody got all mixed up,
like all the fucking Nash and I was
getting mixed up. Like do you know,
started streamlining the looks and
people are way better looking now.
Don't you think then when you look
back in the day, I mean, Jesus Christ,
Babe Ruth, every once in Lou Gehrig was
a good looking guy. You know what I mean?
But Babe Ruth, that guy was
a mess. Joe Dimaggio mess.
I can say what I want.
Bad Looking. I don't know.
I'm just saying when you
look at the shit back then,
like an Italian guy looked a hundred
percent fucking Italian. I don't want to,
you know something.
And when I went to Italy,
they were better look in the back then.
I don't know what the fuck it was.
We allegedly had better food back then.
People were shorter.
I don't know what it was.
Did you ever notice that when you look
back and when you really look at those
old pictures?
I love looking at old pictures and
it's like that George Carlin bit.
When you look at an old
picture and you're like,
everybody in that picture is dead.
If for some reason in a morbid way,
it's like fascinating. When I look
at those old pictures, I just,
that's what I think. I God damn it,
there was some fucking ugly ass people.
You know what I mean? It was a game
changer was, uh, three things. Polio,
vaccine,
penicillin and braces.
Those three fucking things could just
hide so many fucking imperfections.
You know what I mean? And once
you get braces, Jesus Christ,
if you just brush your fucking teeth
in remotely, keep yourself in shape.
You know, you throw on some nice clothes.
People have no idea where you came from.
You know,
back in the day, people, they saw it on
your teeth, told the whole fucking story.
You just smile and be like, hi, I can, I
can see you're going to have tuberculosis.
You live in a damp Dag fucking
apartment with no fucking windows.
You saw it in their fucking teeth,
right? I don't know about it.
Heard what's his face?
Jp Morgan had like Rosacea.
Is that how you say they're all over
his face? He was just all fucking angry.
Those old school rich guys, you know,
he used to walk around with top hats.
It's like the penguin harm while
walking down the street. Um,
is this a podcast anymore? And I don't
even, what the fuck I'm talking about?
Let me, let me do some advertising
here and then I'll, uh,
I'll get to more babbling
here in a moment. All right.
Hot Sauce. A shameless fucking
shameless. She looks in,
bred her fucking teeth.
There's something going on with Tara.
There's some go with you see how Bill
Clinton collapse now. It's like he's a,
like a marionette puppet.
He has his mouth open.
That's how he made it. But that
smiling with his mouth open. Oh,
I'm going to fix it. I'll fix everything.
How you doing? Call me later. Oh.
Oh,
whoa.
I'm sick of Obama's wife.
This is some Republican rants either.
It's just kind of first ladies in general,
you know, I don't know what it is all
throughout my life with each presidency.
Like these first ladies, they've just
gotten more and more like, like a,
like chatty, you know, more,
more chime in in like
leaning into the frame,
fitting out their ideas. It's just
like, well, why are you talking?
You weren't elected.
Shut up.
Your husband's not running a lemonade
stand here. He's running the country.
You don't just Shyman.
Let me guess.
Is this considered sexist?
Hello?
Okay. You're just not at
link. Let me ask you this.
Let's say you had a leak in your
house. Okay? You call a plumber up.
He shows up and he goes, yeah, I took the
links coming from the upstairs bathroom.
We need to shut it off. Then all of a
sudden his wife walks in. Who is it?
A plumber?
What'd you be like with all due respect?
Shut the,
I need a plumber in this moment
sending all of branch here,
right?
At some point there's going to be
the first female president, right?
Exactly.
He's at
that moment.
You're going to have the first male first,
right?
When that happens,
that too needs to shut his trap.
I don't want to hear a word out of him.
I want to hear from the president.
You served. Go do some
first lady stuff. Alright,
go get yourself some gloves
that go up to your elbows.
Smile and nod during speeches.
Go put your own flair.
Redecorating the White House.
Hi.
Shoot.
I'm Michelle Obama right now.
She's sitting there holding up those
Hashtag for that Hashtag bring back our
girls. Remember, it's like,
that blew my mind. It's like,
why are you showing me that?
I'm a stand up comedian,
like what am I going to do
to get those curls back?
Why don't you look across the dinner
table? It's like you see that.
Tell him to pick up a phone call
some navy seals and saw the,
well, what am I going to do?
Show up with a sharp and Mike said,
oh,
it's unreal.
I'll tell you what kills me. Hillary
Clinton might run, she might,
she might run by blows my mind.
She became a center.
She went from being the president's
wife to being a senator just like that
lateral move.
That's like Tom Brady's wife become
the next quarterback of the ramps.
It's like what?
You're hanging out.
You just pick it up.
I sucked at sports and then I bank Tom
Brady and I don't know what happened.
I just picked up a ball.
I started Weiss in it.
I'm leading receivers was incredible.
I knew it was going to be like this
going on his bill burr, and this is
the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
September 14th,
2009 um,
it's like fucking 10 20 at night.
I finally got some time
to do the podcast today.
I was flying back from Philadelphia,
Pennsylvania. I lost my cell phone,
you know, once again, I
lost another cell phone.
Every time I get a nice cell phone,
I lose him.
So I just reactivated
my little flip phone.
Those of you who go on to bill
[inaudible] dot com when you listen to my
podcasts,
you see that picture of me right there
looking down at the bar and that little
15 year old chicks flip phone that I
got there, that's what I'm back to.
I went from a blackberry to that thing,
you know,
just once I would like to lose a fucking
phone and call it and have someone on
the other end be my savior.
Be like, why? Yes, yes.
I have found your phone and I
would love to return it to you.
There was nothing more. I would like to
do the maternity now, free of charge,
free of charge. That's what happens
to everybody else. I know you talked,
my girlfriend loses her cell phone. She
calls up. She just, you know, oh my God,
I have my cell phone and that
she just picks up Mike. She goes,
let me use your phone. And
then she just goes, you know,
rings like twice and it's always the
nicest person ever on the other line.
She's like, Hey, yeah, yeah,
it is mine. I thank you. Oh,
that's awesome. Oh, okay. Got It. Right.
And then I'm driving her somewhere
to go pick the fucking thing.
That never happens for me.
It just rings and rings and rings and
then I just hear my voicemail. Hey,
this is bill.
You've reached my cell phone that
you're never going to fucking see again.
Please leave a message and you
might want to call river, you know,
call fucking Verizon and avid shutoff is
for somebody calls Trinidad on this God
damn thing. Fuck. So that was my day.
This is how old I am too. You know what?
When I was flying out here, there was a,
there was nobody sitting next to me and
actually he was fell asleep, you know,
laying down on the row.
And when I woke up,
like I felt like my lower body
dislocated from my upper body.
It wasn't even like my back hurt.
It was just like,
I felt like I hit by a fucking car.
It's been a brutal day is what
I'm trying to say. People.
But my weekend in Philly was awesome.
So many people showed up.
So many people showed up. We added a show
that's never happened to me, you know?
So I want to thank everybody.
Before I get going on this
long rambling podcast here,
I want to thank everybody in
Philadelphia who came out to see me.
I had a great time and I was
working there with, uh, Joe to Rosa,
the a teen idol,
the new hot shot teen idol on the opiod.
Anthony show was opening up for me and,
uh,
all my God did the Raiders just score
a fucking touchdown is in no flag.
Holy Shit. Are they finally
going to beat the charges?
Okay. I don't want to ruin you guys.
Who Anybody Tivo the fucking game.
They just went up 1917 with two 34 left.
You know, it's funny, I
was supposed to have a bet,
you know I'm a patriots fan and I was
supposed to bet these guys shredding
Reagan out in Buffalo,
right?
I made him a $50 bet last year when Tom
Brady went down that they are patriots
who are gonna make the playoffs. Cause
they was saying that they would done.
So if the Patriots didn't
make the playoffs, I on
both 50 bucks. But if I won,
they had to read a written apology to
build Bella check that I wrote and they
had to read it on the air.
We went 11 and five but we didn't make it.
So I owed him 50 bucks, but I never went
to buffalo and it can never pay him.
So Lo and behold, the first
game of season, we're playing
buffalo. So I go, hey,
let's go double or nothing, you
know? And they wouldn't touch it.
They would not touch the fucking
game on air. I was like, dude,
the worst you could do is break even.
And then they still,
they still wouldn't back their own
team and look at the fucking game.
They actually almost want it.
They were actually did win it.
They just blew the game.
But uh, so I'm glad,
I'm glad I saved myself. 50 bucks each.
Shredding Regen. If you listen to this,
you guys punked out. And you know what's
funny was when I got off the plane,
I actually got a message from
one of the guys that works.
There's t trying to get me to
call in at the last second.
I bet a lot of their listeners call them
punks for not taking the bet. And uh,
unfortunately I'd lost my cell
phone or I would've called in,
but it worked out for me.
Um,
I'm too fucking frazzled to do this guys.
I really am. I can't fucking do this,
but I got to get this done because I got
too much shit to do tomorrow usually.
And I enjoyed doing the podcast.
It's usually in the morning.
I'm usually screaming and I'm having a
good fucking time, but now it's late.
My dog's asleep.
My downstairs neighbors asleep downstairs.
Neighbor doesn't like us.
We have hardwood floors and my
girlfriend has high heel shoes.
So you can do the math on that one. Let's
just get, let's just cut to the chase.
You guys mind if I do a short one this
week? Yeah. Well to fucking bed. Um,
let me, let me give you some happy shit
because this isn't going to be happy.
I'm fucking exhausted. Let me give you
some youtube videos to watch this week.
All right. This first one, um,
I stumbled across because someone
else showed me something else.
Um,
this video which you want to search
is it says try not to laugh or say
WTF. Basically what the fuck. But
you just write WTF all lowercase.
Try not to laugh or say WTF and a,
I'm have a feeling a lot of women won't
find it funny because it's just really
like you'd have to be in the seventh
grade or a mail to find this funny.
I can't even explain why.
It's why it's funny,
but it just makes me laugh my ass off.
But it's,
it's a great video cause you will either
laugh or you will say, what the fuck?
Um, here's another one.
Somebody sent me a search,
gay top gun.
You guys ever seen the movie top gun?
And you've seen Tarantino goes on his
rant that it's actually a homo erotic
movie. The way this person
edits it is fucking hilarious.
And I haven't seen the movie.
Oh my God,
I probably haven't seen that movie since
the late eighties. You know, I remember,
I saw, did I see in the movie theaters
now? I think somebody bought it.
So many, my family bought that movie that
was actually considered a good movie,
you know, and uh, you know,
we had it on Vhs, so, you know,
the usual life of a VHS tape,
it lasted like a fucking year then it
was all screwed up from being rewound,
you know? So I haven't seen it basically
since of what have 89 or 90 and uh,
I got to go with Tarantino on that one.
At least the way this Guy Edison movie,
man, it's fucking, it's
really funny. All right.
The last youtube video you might
want to check out at this one.
And I'm just search a dance kick baby.
Alright. Comedian, last night who I
worked with, very funny guy told me to uh,
Jeff and I've already forget
his last name. I'm such a
moron. He was hilarious. So,
uh, he told me to check this
while dance kicked baby. Um,
it's, it's, I can't say it's funny. It,
it'll definitely make you put
your hand over your mouth. Um,
cause it's not dance kicked baby.
It's not that.
It's dancing and then a baby gets
kicked. All right? You want to,
if you want to see what happens when a
toddler gets fucking, just check it out.
All right. There's a lot of sick fucks
are going to look at that one first. Um,
like I said, this is going to
be real economical, economical,
whoever the fuck you say at this week,
uh, let's plow ahead. Here's some advice.
Somebody wants to listen to this story.
This one really a,
this one really grabbed me here
on a lot of levels. All right,
bill asked bill a bill.
I was at a family birthday party
today when some friends of mine,
friends of my dad's showed up with
their smoking hot daughter, um,
make after making a few
glances at each other.
I figured I had a good chance of
getting her number. I went over to her,
my dad introduced us and we made a little
small talk. Her mom then asked if a,
she wanted a piece of cake or anything.
So I decided to be a fucking gentleman
and offered to get her a piece.
So I come back with a slice of cake
in hand only to see my brother,
and he's written this in capital letters.
So you know,
this isn't going to go anywhere good.
He goes,
I come back only to see my brother
capital letters talking to her,
um,
and already getting her number on the
guys that she's interested in getting into
law enforcement and he
happens to be a cop. Uh,
that pretty much canceled me out since
there's no way I was going to pull the
same shit in which both brothers
asked her for her number. Yeah.
That would've been creepy. So he goes, uh,
I handed the cake and the three of us
talk some more until her parents decided
to leave since it was towards
the end of the party already. Um,
after that, after they left, I
immediately told my brother, you know,
walked up to my brother and I told him,
what the fuck.
Since everybody could tell I
was trying to get our number.
He joked along with my,
what is that?
U. N. D. E. S. I don't
know what that word means.
Eat all my uncles. I couldn't read that.
Sorry. This is volumes up way too high.
Here. Let me turn this
thing down. Sorry. Um,
record level.
I don't know. I don't know how to
fucking do that on the fly to it.
Does that work? That's better. Hello? No,
it's still fucked up. All right. Whatever.
I'll hold the mic away from me.
Told you guys,
this one's going to be brutal
and exhausted. Um, anyways,
so he goes, yeah. So I went up
to him. I said, what the fuck?
Since everyone could tell I
was trying to get a number.
He joked along with my uncles
saying she's 26 and uh,
I guess he's 20 and his brother,
the cop is 21.
So he choked her with his uncle,
said, come on man, she's 26.
She's out of your league. And that
he beat me to it. I figured, yeah,
I guess he did and didn't.
Uh,
so I did make a big deal
or anything after that.
Since I'm not a little bitch,
who's going to cry about it?
I'm going to cry about some twice number.
However,
I still thought it was fucked up.
If it had been the other way around,
I would have just let
my brother do his thing.
I guess it comes down to the bar scene
where if you step away to get a bitch of
drink, you're leaving the field pretty
much open for anybody else. I don't know.
Do you think it was a fucked up
move or just part of the game? Uh,
thanks and hope to see you on stage soon.
Um,
well what do I think
about that? Ah, all right.
I don't want to blame the victim here,
but what I learned in that letter is
that your brother's kind of a dick.
You know,
that's kind of a dick move.
And uh, you know, I wouldn't have
done that to my brother, but you know,
he's doing it to you that that's, that's
a dick move. And you live with the guy.
So you know he's a Dick.
You know what I mean?
And you kind of answered the question.
Yeah, you never, you never leave.
First of all, even if you know,
even if he didn't come over,
you're already setting up the
relationship that, you know,
you're just going to be
fetching her stuff, offering
her, you know, are you cold?
Do you want me to get you a blanket?
You know, you don't wanna be that guy.
You know your brother.
I don't know.
I really want to make fun of the fact
that he went to law enforcement a,
let me teach you how to be a cop. All
right? This is how your Fris somebody,
you know, but believe me,
you use what you got. You,
you think I have never met
her fucking good looking girl.
And I said, uh, you know,
worked away in that I was a comedian and
an invited her to his show her in one
of her friends hoping desperately she
would only show up by herself so I could
try and fucking banger. So I can't
get mad at him for that. Um, yeah,
in the future I would just, I just
wouldn't do that shit around your brother.
That's a really asshole thing and I
think you need to get him back somehow.
I want to, I want a story of revenge
from you. That's what I want.
But the end of the day do the chicks
fucking 26 years old and you know,
she's got a 21 year old trying to
figure out our future, you know,
she's a loser and plus, you know, just the
way you were talking about it, you know,
I learned a, you know, you
never leave a bitch alone to,
you just wanted to fuck her anyways.
Right. So whatever lesson learned,
lesson learned, and to use the top
gun analogy, your brother is now,
he's not a wing man. He's not a good
wing men. So fuck that guy. And uh,
I dunno,
you know what you could do,
this is something I used to do way back
in the day when I was in Boston and I
used to go to this place,
daisy Buchanan's on Newbury street,
which was a total fucking meat
market and I'm sure it still is.
I used to go in there with a,
with a couple friends of mine,
you know, going there, you know,
I have a couple of drinks and just
start talking shit to girls or whatever.
Trying to fucking hook up because God
knows that's easy to have three guys.
That's always a nice magic number.
No wonder we never hooked up.
But we used to go in there
and I forgot what you just called it,
dropping bombs.
I can't remember what it was,
but basically you wouldn't cock block,
but she would definitely fuck
with your friend. If he was,
you'd see him hitting on a
girl and it was going well.
You'd walk up to him and you would just
make up some detail about his life.
That would be embarrassing,
that he would have to somehow play off.
Um, unless she got serious
and you really got mad.
Like a buddy of mine did one time and
mentioned that a friend of mine was still
living in the basement with his mom.
That's what he said.
He had just got done striking out.
So then he came walking up,
all hammered and he's like,
Oh yeah, this guy was fucked.
This guy was one of these dudes.
You know all those guys who like who
look up at the ceiling when they talk.
And he was one of those guys and he just
came walking up and that's what he said.
He goes, Oh yeah, yeah,
you liked this guy.
Hey did you mentioned that you
still live at home with you?
And he said it really angry.
You know what else this guy
did as a classic story? I
kept leaving in a fucking,
told us we were in daisy
Buchanan is one night, right?
It was just one of those nights, you
know, I dunno what we were talking,
the women were responding.
We were like, Holy Shit,
this is going great for once because
believe me, we did not do well.
There's a reason I had to get on a stage
and act like a jackass. Okay. So, uh,
I don't know what happened. Met this group
of girls and it was going great and I,
we all having a good time and everybody
kind of paired off, everybody was vibing,
right? And um, all of a sudden
you just felt the whole energy,
energy of the bar just look towards the
front door was like somebody, you know,
famous or, or something
was going on. You know,
like when all of a sudden
there's like a commotion,
everybody just looks in that
direction, right. So it was weird.
Everybody just sort of
collectively looked at the doors,
like a wave that went across
the room every second.
Everybody felt the energy just looked
in the direction you felt the energy
coming from. And we look over
at the door and I swear to God,
what the fuck just happened?
San Diego just scored Jesus Christ.
Fucking Raiders.
God Damn fucking guys.
Just can they ever beat San Diego? All
right, let me plow ahead. So they fucking,
um,
everybody just goes and looks at the door
and we look over and there's this guy
dressed like Elvis fucking
Elvis impersonator.
This is the most bizarre cock block
I ever got. This guy standing there,
of course like fat Elvis, some
comic did that joke. Nobody,
nobody ever dresses up like the in shape
Elvis because no one was ever that good
looking. They always dress like the
fat one or something like that. Right.
So everyone's just fat Elvis.
He's got the fucking, you know,
right before he overdosed on pills,
sunglasses on,
and he was doing all like these moves
to whatever music was on and uh,
he fucking, yeah, like every girl
in the bar and was like, oh my God,
they all fucking ran over
to the guy. Yeah. Right.
So it was like everything was going great
with could we're going to hook up and
next thing you know,
fucking fake.
Elvis walks in and the girls just run
away and they all run up to the guy
because they don't want to get
like their picture taken with them,
a fucking whatever. So every guy in the
bar were kind of stand like, yeah, duty.
You fuck you gotta be kidding me.
Right till my buddy who looks
up at the ceiling, he has,
he walks up to the guy, you know,
and the guy standing up to a meeting,
everybody will show up, man. How
you doing? All right. All right.
Taking care of business. How you doing
buddy? Like doing the Elvis thing.
He's got the fucking leg
shaking and everything. So my
buddy goes up there, right?
And he starts shaking the
guy's hand. He's like, well,
shut up my Maya and my buddy's
like squeezing his hand. Right?
And he's looking up at the ceiling.
Yeah,
but the fake Elvis can tell these pissed.
He's like, what? What's the mind of man?
And my body's just like, he goes, hey
dude. He's like squeezing in his hand.
He goes, hey buddy, why can't
you just be yourself? You know?
He's like looking up the same way
because why can't you just be yourself?
You know? He goes, I like the red sox.
I don't come in here dressed like
Roger Clemens and the guys like going,
he's Kinda dropping character going, all
right man. All right dude. All right.
All right.
Like his voice has changed it and they
start having this fucking handshake fight,
squeezing each other's hands.
And they were about ready to go at it.
And at that point I was like,
I was gonna see the greatest thing ever
because my buddy was big. I was like,
if he fucking punches this fake Elvis and
I see those plastic glasses helicopter
off of his fucking face, ah,
please let him be wearing a wig.
And right before they did it was like,
you ever see like a Nhl game when the
ref steps in right before two goons are
gonna go at it. The guy fucking
broke it up, but it was still good.
My buddy had a fucking handshake
fight with Elvis impersonator.
It really just broke the guy down.
That's what I loved. Everyone is like,
oh my God, Elvis, what's
going on? I thought you died.
No Man, I'm always alive.
He's just playing along. Oh God. Let me
get a picture of the okay on it. You know,
he's doing all that shit and then
my buddy just comes up. Hey Dude,
why can't you just be yourself?
Ah, fuck. Those were some drunk
days. All right, let's plow ahead.
What the fuck was I talking about?
Yeah. You know what, dude? MMM.
Two things I would tell you
when your brother, first of all,
don't fucking hit on women when you're
around your fucking conti brother.
And if he does pull some
shit like that, uh, you know,
you got to do something that you,
this is what you gotta do to that guy.
What you have to do is the next
time he's hitting on a girl,
you have to deliberately
go over and fuck it up.
You got to figure out
some way to fuck it up.
And what you're doing here is you're kind
of shooting one across the bow just to
let them know that if he
does that shit to you again,
that there will be like repercussions.
You know what I mean?
And then just get the fuck away
from the guy and continue on.
You know you're doing fine. Right. You
had no problem walking up to the girl.
He had a strategy. You're good. But
yeah, there's no, there's no sense dude.
You're 20 years old, man. You're
in fucking mint condition.
He don't eat some fucking 26 year
old we can do with that. Right.
I know you'd fucker. Exactly, but
you're not going to marry you, right?
You don't have any feelings for us. A
fucking fucker. And Fuck your brother.
Fucking 20 year, 21 year old cop
cop were at the mall. How did he,
how long do you have to go to
school to be a cop? You know?
Anybody else have that?
Like you went to,
there's a kid in the grade above you
and he's like the biggest maniac ever.
And then you become a senior and
next thing you know he's coming in,
he's breaking up keg parties
and you're like, dude,
I was in shop class with you six months
ago. No, I'm a police officer now.
Wow. Well full on. You've
got the gun and everything.
I think I just missed a
fucking unbelievable game
doing this God damn podcast.
It was two scores late in the game.
You know what I hate about football?
I hate how they always show the Douche
bags who dress up like they're going to
the rocky horror picture show. You know
what I mean? I went to a Raiders game.
Not everybody is dressed like a
douchebag and make no mistake.
Those are douchebags.
Okay.
There's people who fucking make a
hat out of a football. You know,
they did it the Patriots game too.
I was joking with my buddy, I go,
can't they just show some regular fan
who looks like he has season tickets and
could actually talk about the game?
This guy had like a, you know,
silver glitter on his
face with the Patriots.
Amble people wearing football
helmets to the game. You know,
it's almost like the guy in the TV
truck is just telling the cameraman,
just find the biggest douche bag you can
find. That's what we're going to show.
I went to, I went to a Raiders game
a couple of years ago. Man, it was,
it was great. You know,
just a legendary place.
Even though it's been a while
since they've had a lot of success.
They did go to a super bowl,
gets Tampa Bay a few years ago,
but I actually met this older guy,
man.
He had like the Ken Stabler silver and
white beard at some booze on his breath.
You know,
he's a football fan.
If I wasn't sitting there dressed
like Boba Fett is fucking dumb.
Hate people do that shit. All
right, let's plow ahead here. Um,
all right. Uh, Bill,
I was bored and thought I might
give you something to think about.
I live in Europe and would love to move
to the u s but I have no idea how to
even apply or even if
it's a good time to do it.
I'm 30 and I've been stalling for years,
but I don't want to pack a bag and just
end up as a some homeless guy in the
corner in America.
I've always loved New York as the idea,
as the idea of this,
that city.
What as the idea of a city that
never sleeps fits me. I'm, as,
I'm a little older now,
I've already seen most of my friends
friends leave into the domestic lifestyle
and I just can't fit into that yet.
I spent a lot of time alone for a few
years and it's just like your act,
you start going a little crazy. Um,
I feel like an observer in life,
so I do and say stuff just to
see what happens sometimes.
Would it be, sorry I'm scrolling
down here. Would be a good ground.
Would that be a good
ground for comedy maybe?
Or should I have started in my twenties
I also play guitar and people have said
I might have something
musically for years,
but I was always a coward in my youth
and couldn't get on stage unless I was
hammered.
So I never got anywhere.
Now I'm worried I lost too many screws
and as my social network has begun
failing,
I just get the bitter alone
against the word world feeling.
It feels like I'm at a crossroads.
Everything I've seen in life seems like
a weird dream and I'm surrounded by
strangers. What do you think? I
think that's pretty fucking deep. Um,
what is, well, if you're not married,
you don't have any kids and you want
to always wanted to move to New York,
just fucking do it.
Save up some money and just do what
you're never going to regret. You know?
Or if you live in America and you're
like, Hey, I always want to go to Paris,
what would happen if I just fucking
went there? Do it. The very least.
You just got to get some great stories.
You know,
you're going to come over
wherever you're going to go.
You're going to have an accent.
You're gonna Hook Up.
It's going to be a good time. I would
definitely say to go and don't mind.
Fuck yourself into thinking
you're too old to do shit.
Look failing. The, uh,
uh, how do we put this
failing is overrated is far as
like the pain that people have.
It's not doing it because I have
a lot of fucking regrets in life.
I got a lot of undergrads,
I'm not going to get into them,
but I got a lot of fucking regrets
and I've failed a lot as a comedian,
but none of them really hurt cause
I just kept doing it. You know,
remember that old Michael
Jordan commercial where he
talks about shooting the
basketballs, all the shots
he's missed. He's like,
I failed over and over and over and
over again and that's why I succeed.
You got to take that mentality through.
Failing is fucking hilarious. Failing is,
it's the best stories. It's the funniest
fucking stories. Watch when people,
when actors go and they
do panel on talk shows,
they never talk about,
you know, oh I did this.
The bad guests go on there and talk.
Oh, I work with his director. Oh my God,
he was so great.
But the good guests go on there and they
talk about bad auditions that they had
or stupid things that they did in the
great movie that they're promoting.
That's what the fuck you do, you
know, to kill as a guest. Look at me.
I'm a little tired. I'm, I'm,
I'm making a different point now.
Now I'm telling you how to kill doing
panel even though I've never fucking done
it. Um, yeah, dude moved in New York.
You're not gonna be homeless.
It's like a big river and you just
jump in and you just start swimming.
But from the outside it looks impossible.
But once you go there, you're fine.
You know? And if you do an up homeless,
fortunately it's a walkable city,
so there's plenty of people to panhandle.
Although if you're white,
you might have a rough
time. At least. I did.
Did it one day as a joke just
to see what people would do.
I was dressed really nicely and it
just had a cup. Excuse me sir. Sir,
could you spare a little change?
Just trying to get home,
try and make a phone call.
But I had a shit eating grin,
so I didn't make any money.
All right, next question.
Now I'm plowing ahead
this week, people. Uh,
all right. Hey Bill. I'm a huge fan.
Thank you. Thank you very much. All right.
You won't be after this
low energy podcast, um,
throughout my life no
matter what I've done, I've,
I am known for being a horrible child.
All right guys, let's stop here. Uh,
just let's just remember that I
barely got out of college and I have a
communications degree.
So let me communicate with you right now
and let you know that if you guys are
going to go real deep,
cause I had somebody sent me like one,
they would like suicidal and uh,
I kind of didn't touch it because a,
I didn't want to give the wrong advice.
I was going to say go talk to
somebody quite qualified, you know,
and don't kill yourself. All
right, so let's try it. Let's,
you know, let's, let's back off the
throttle a little bit here. People,
this is supposed to be a funny podcast.
All right.
The light guy just walking around feeling
like it's the dream and I'm alone.
You know, I, that's when it starts getting
like, all right, I've had those thoughts.
Well, I guess I've had those
thoughts so I can relate. You know,
I thought about killing myself.
A lot of people think that shit,
you just don't do it.
You know what I mean?
It's like leg sweep and a chick. You
think about it, you just don't do it.
But if someone makes a video of it, you
fucking watch it. And it's hilarious. Um,
all right, let's plow through
here. Throughout my life,
no matter what I've done,
I've always been known for being
a horrible child. All right?
This guy has gotten right to the root
of his paint. No matter what I did,
it wasn't good enough.
Um,
I think I'm pretty and I feel bad
cause I mean making fun of people as if
fucking really opening up here. So
let me stop doing that. All right. Uh,
I think I'm a pretty good kid
compared to, uh, the people.
I know my grades aren't that good,
but hey, I haven't gotten held back.
Well as a positive way of looking
at it. You got a D in math? Yeah.
Did I stay back?
Will I write then shut the fuck up.
I'm 15 and I have an older brother, two
years older and I have a younger brother,
two years younger. Uh, the
younger one is annoying.
So if he starts bothering me, I say
something to him telling him to stop.
Um, oh, when I do that, I'm being a dick.
What?
I'm being a dick.
When I could just slap him or something
and then he does the classic shit and
screams like clockwork and my parents will
come in and punish, make, oh yeah, dude,
I've been there. I had three younger
brothers. I've been there. Um,
if he was bothering me first, Oh, if he,
they punish you if he was even
bothering you first, um, what,
what you gotta do is you've got
to muffle his voice with a pillow.
Or you can go the opposite route is
you can torch room by tickling them is
basically you sit on their arms
and you do the typewriter thing.
You know what I mean?
There's a lot of other ways to make,
obviously the slap isn't going to work
cause he knows he's going to get you in
trouble that way.
So you got to come up with creative
ways to torture your younger brother.
Start with doing it when your
parents aren't home. All right,
why am I telling people to
do this shit? All right. Uh,
let me go and at some point they need to
stop babying him instead of taking his
side because he's the youngest.
And then there's my somewhat perfect
older brother who was always in the
limelight. I admit, I'm jealous. I mean,
he makes honor role plays football and
works all at the same time and I'm just
the fuck up in the middle.
Why is it middle kid always feel fucking
neglected I guess cause you're in the
middle. I was so, you know, second oldest.
I don't know where the fuck I was. Um, he
has always been treated better than me.
I'm his best friend
got him in trouble for,
for laying trash cans on fire back when
he was in the seventh grade and my dad
cursed him out and told him to never
hang ultra cursed out the other kid and
told him not to hang out with
my older brother again. Uh,
what happens in the 12th grade?
I'm there hanging out again
and my parents don't say shit.
I have a bad friend and I haven't
even gotten in trouble with them,
but my parents won't let
me hang out with them.
My parents let my older brother learned
how to drive when he was 12 and I'm
turning 16 and they
haven't taught me shit.
I probably won't get a
damn license until I'm 25
then they treat me like shit. Last week
I cleaned my bathroom and left, uh,
my mini trash cans sitting outside the
bathroom and instead of being glad they
go eight, because I leave the
trashcan outside the bedroom.
Please tell me what you think
about this situation. Uh, yeah.
You're getting the middle child treatment,
you're getting the middle child
treatment and this is what I would say,
beat up your younger brother when your
parents aren't around or maybe break some
of his shit when he's not in his
room and a, your older brother, uh,
you can cut the brake lines on his
car. Now I'm fucking with you. Um, uh,
you know what? Fuck them. Fuck them. If
they don't want to pay attention to you,
fuck them. Just keep doing your
thing. And I make a joke out of it.
You know, you know you left a
trashcan outside the bathroom. I know.
What was I thinking? I should have been
like my older brother and lit it on fire.
You're absolutely right. At what point
did you realize you were bored with me?
Huh?
When the newer version of me came along
and then when she tries to interrupt,
just be like, no dad, dad, I get it.
You don't care. You don't, I'm
the Middle Kid. What do you think?
I don't want you to Brady bunch.
I saw what Jen went through.
I'm going through the same shit.
They bring up that shit about driving.
Huh?
How bad a driver was my older brother
that you just decided not to teach any of
us, you know, I dunno.
Just go with that route. But you know,
above all, don't take it personally.
You just focus on your own life.
You've got to understand,
you're probably walking around
in 15 you know, you know,
you're at that age where you
kind of think you know some shit,
but you kind of know that you
don't know a lot of other shit,
that that feeling never goes away and
your parents are walking around thinking
the same shit. So, uh, don't take them too
seriously. You know, unless they tell you,
you know, not to do drugs or
hanging out with that Douche bag,
you probably shouldn't be hanging out
with them. But you know what I mean?
I don't, I don't have to tell you,
dude. It's like that's shit that you,
you're going to get through.
It gets better when you're in your
twenties you know, and you never know.
Your brother might have peaked that
am so a lot of people, you know,
if they get in fucking
late in high school,
like do you want to say
how great your life is?
If you're actually on the football team
and you're fucking a cheerleader in high
school, I mean, I don't
know how you ever beat that.
You have to become like
a fucking movie star.
Like there's nowhere for those people to
go. That's why so many of those people,
they, when they go out in the
real world, they, they, they,
they fail because they've always been,
I mean, you're king of the
world. You're on a football team.
You're banging a cheerleader,
right? You both in your teens,
your bodies are in mint fucking
condition and you don't have to pay rent.
And if you do some dumb shit,
you still charged as a juvenile.
I'm going to tell you right now, it's
never going to get better than that. Okay?
Are you going to go a long fucking way
as an adult to make it better than that?
Okay.
So you know,
I don't know if I'm cheering you up here,
but you know it's been in the middle of
being in that mix is not a bad fucking
thing. Being in the middle of the
herd. Cause then you can break out.
You can try to figure out what you want
to do and then the fact that people kind
of Shit on you, you get a good sense of
humor. You already wrote some funny shit.
You'll be fine. You are fuck your
older brother and your younger brother.
What are you thinking about that?
I know what to tell you, dude.
I just don't want to fuck you
up dude. I don't, I don't,
I don't have the background to give a 15
year old fucking advice. I really don't,
but I, I hope I made some sort of
sense, but don't take it too seriously.
All right.
You know what I would do?
I would always clean the bathroom and
always leave the trashcan out there just
to deliberately annoy your parents and
then act slightly retarded to the point
that they actually think back to some
drugs that they did when they were single.
And that's why you're fucked up now,
you know, do some shit like that.
Just passive aggressive stuff.
Started having fun with the fact
that they don't pay attention to you.
In other words, act out. That's what I'm
trying to say. All right, so let's recap.
Break your younger brother's shit.
Cut The brake lines and
your older brother's car.
Ignore your parents and act
slightly retarded. All right,
that's my advice. Um, oh, here's
something for you. I got good. I wrote a,
I got good feedback from a woman. I don't
get this very often and said, hey bill,
just wanted to comment on your response
to the guy who got shot down at the
sandwich shop a couple of weeks ago.
That was a loaded question and for
what it's worth from a female fan,
I thought your answer was
incredibly fair as well as funny.
It is bullshit that men generally
have the burden of approaching women.
And I know that burned is asked to have
her look at him like a Disgusting Chore,
but just because She's pretty,
doesn't mean she owes everybody.
Whoever tits honor of fucking thank you
card. I really appreciate your answer.
You could have gone a much easier
and shittier root. Thanks. Yeah,
you mean like how he did with the 15
year old kids question. All right.
Every once in a while I get positive
feedback feedback from a female,
so I got to read it. All right, next one.
I'm just going to read this
like a book this week. People.
I'm literally nodding off here. A as
bill. Hey Bill. Uh, throughout my life,
no matter what I've done,
and I already read this
already. Read this one, right?
Jesus Christ. All right. Oh,
here's some letters from people overseas,
specifically England.
This section's called English [inaudible].
Hey Bill.
So you thought my last email wasn't
good enough for your podcast.
I hold no grudges. It's a recession
and you want to keep it all American.
Fairplay.
So let's keep up the theme from your
last one in attempt to get a mention,
a shameless whoring of myself here.
Uh, you say baseball jumped the shark.
Let me tell you something. Coming from
the nation that pretty much invent,
invented all major sports except
the Olympics. Great Britain.
You know, I like to consider myself
knowledgeable about sports. Uh,
exactly.
What sports did you create?
Egan do the rugby thing and then
rugby developed into football.
I'll give you that one. That,
that was the spawn of it. But you,
you can't take credit for baseball.
We're going can say that's cricket.
You guys sit there with that fraternity
paddle from some horrific night of
hazing.
You finally pulled it out
of some freshmen's ass and
now you're tried to hit a
racket ball over to some
guy from fucking India. Huh?
What other sports have you guys invented?
Basketball. You didn't invent that.
I don't know what you guys invented, but
you sure suck at all of them. You know,
when's the last time you guys
won a World Cup? You know what?
That's a great fucking question. That's
what you guys are known for soccer, right?
And rugby. Like when those
douchebags over in England tried to,
they always try to say that that foot
football players are pussies because they
were like helmets and that type of shit.
And then you watch a rugby game.
Those guys are tough. But those guys
would be hitting each other a lot,
fucking harder if they had
pads on and shit. You know,
I watched the game.
Yeah.
It's a bunch of guys fucking stick in
their heads up each other's asses as
they're kicking at a football.
That's definitely, and I know,
you know what's funny is I never
disrespect rugby. I look at it like that.
That's a tough sport and
tough guys play that sport.
I don't know why they always
pick on football. I don't get it.
You know what I mean?
Dude,
Ray Lewis would fuck up at least five
of your rugby players by himself without
pads.
You got nobody in your fucking little
pussy ass English rugby league that looks
anything like Ray Lewis let
ray Lewis would destroy him.
Jack Lambert,
once you bring them,
bring me your famous fucking rugby guys
and show me how those guys are hitting
any harder than Lawrence Taylor.
You're out of your fucking minds.
How do you fucking minds?
Let's look up England,
England.
World Cup victory.
I'm going to make a guess and I'm
going to say it's, it's somewhere.
It's gotta be the 1960s or before
England World Cup victory.
The World Cup victory by England.
1966. There you go. I fucking knew it.
I knew it was going be back then.
Like when the Celtics were winning
all their championships, right?
Was Brazil not allowed in back
then? Fucking pattern. Your stats.
Um, I'm just fucking with you guys. I
respect your sports, but I, you know what,
what are you pretty much adventure
all major sports except the Olympics.
Go Fuck Yourself.
You guys didn't invent shit.
You had a halfass idea that we
made tremendous. Is there any,
you know what I mean? Like the greatest
fucking soccer player of all time. He's,
is he from England?
It's Palae.
The Michael Jordan of soccer
is not even from England's.
Why don't you guys dominate something on
a world fucking level. I want what, what?
What was the last time
you guys had an athlete?
Cause I'll tell you right now that good
looking son of a bitch for the La Galaxy
is not doing shit and nobody
gives a fuck about him over here.
You can walk up and buy a ticket.
All right.
I went to La Galaxy fucking game.
I parked right next to the guy.
I didn't even recognize him. I asked
him which way the fucking stadium was.
The only reason why I knew he was on the
fucking galaxies cause he already had
his fucking cleats on. All right.
He can't wait to go back there.
Um, all right, the fuck Bob
Beckham. All right, well let me,
let me get back to this fucking thing.
Ah, I think I come from some authority.
Oh yeah. Once you pat yourself
on the back a little more.
Your English cont here we go. Baseball
always fucking sucked. No it didn't.
And I'll tell you why it's a game suited
for America like no other hours of time
to kill between meaningful play.
Meaningful for some reason is two words,
meaning full,
like what is the meaning of the
word? And I ate too much. Um, full,
meaningful as one word.
Get Dumb cunt.
Take the last l off the full and smash
them together. Jesus. I hope that's right.
Her and I just made an ass out of
myself. Uh, between meaningful, um, play.
Allowing for re the required TV,
advertising and selling of Shit.
Overpriced food and poor beer.
Oh Jesus Christ. Really? You
don't have any advertising there?
There's advertising all over
the fizz advertising on the
fucking ball in England.
You know what? Maybe if you guys scored
more than once every fucking 90 minutes.
You know what I mean? You could stick
some commercials in there. Jesus Christ.
The soccer is like hockey without the
skates and the scoring and the fighting
and everything.
That makes it great.
You ever see like a little sissy
get tripped out and I don't know,
during recess and he rolls
around in the ground.
It makes such a big
fucking deal out of it.
You want to beat him with his own books.
That's what like watching soccer is
like every five seconds. These guys,
they look like if,
if Pau Gasol,
if you could have like whatever 20 Pau
Gasol is all in the same fucking field,
just bitch and Moan and with that crybaby
fucking face, that's what soccer is.
See what you did do it.
I actually really enjoy the game,
but you're attacking my shits
and I get attack yours. Um,
minimal athleticism required. Yeah, dude,
really hitting a baseball is one of
the hardest thing you do ever do.
Why don't you fucking brush
your teeth and give it a chance.
At some point you guys are swinging
with that big fucking paddle.
Okay. All right. Let me go. You know,
I would never make fun of the bicycle
kick and act like that's a simple thing to
do anyways.
And before you come up with this stock,
we'd like to see you face a hundred
mile an hour curve. I just did that.
That's hilarious.
From insert drugged up goon
here and then talk that shit.
It's a game. Not a sport.
Like bowling is a game
now. It isn't. I can, I can
see a bowling's a game. It's
just you standing there.
If somebody was throwing the bowling
ball at your head at a hundred miles an
hour and it was fucking changing speeds,
then that would be a sport.
Okay.
Or if he just held the ball like tee ball,
you just hit it off the stand.
Then it would just be, that would just
be a game. I don't know. Athletes,
athletes or people who actually move
around for the majority of the sport,
cyclists,
rowers,
even soccer players cover
around 10 k per game. Oh God.
Really? Is that why they
were all built like women?
You know what your athletes
look in fucking England.
They look like mannequins at the gap.
You know? I know we're fed over here,
but we're more muscular to you fucking
pansies over there with your poor
nutrition in your
nationwide healthcare plan.
Why don't you get some
fucking protein in your diets?
The skinny ass fucking arms and
your little legs running around,
not being able to,
you know why you can't use your fucking
hands and soccer cause you fags would
break your risks. All right. That
was homophobic. Sorry about that.
Didn't mean to say fag. Sorry. Just
get worked up. Anyways, let's come.
Let's finish this. The game comes
from an old English game of rounders,
which was by and large a game of women.
The fuck is he talking about now? You
know, I don't even give a shit anymore.
Whilst me, we, me were, while the real me,
we're playing rugby and football.
What?
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
You're trying to say baseball was made
up by a woman as how he trying to say,
you know what,
I love.
Everybody acts like they fucking hate
America and they can't stop paying
attention to us. I don't listen to any
English douchebags podcast. You know,
I don't know a fucking thing.
All I know Tony Blair,
Tony Blair bitched up and
fucking sent you guys, you know,
got you guys into fucking Iraq too. Cause
he didn't have any balls. You know why?
Because he plays soccer. Wow. That
was really fucking me. Alright.
Underrated checkout. This
Scottish comedian, Frankie
Boyle, very dark but funny.
Scottish guys are fucking hilarious.
Um,
I look forward to your [inaudible] reply
and if I do get past your filtering
process, fucking up reading this
out loud. Well, I did all of that.
I don't have any filtering process.
I read all of these God damn things.
I have nothing better to do. Where are
we in this podcast? 44 fucking minutes.
All right, let's get to some
overrated, underrated. Um,
what the fuck are we going?
All right. Overrated. Uh,
okay. Overrated drummer Neil Peart. Now,
before all the prog rock tech heads,
start quoting modern drummer here me out.
We've had the technology since the
1960s to program a computer to play poly
rhythmic beats.
Try having garage band play
Elvin Jones or Rashied Ali.
I don't know who that is. Um,
dude, you can't say that man.
Those are different kinds of drums.
Although I'm not really into Neil Peart.
I'm not until, I think he's, I don't
know. He's just too fucking on the beat.
He sounds like a robot. He's fucking
amazing. But uh, I like, I dunno,
I think people either like John
Bonham. Oh, you like Neil Peart.
You know what I mean? Nobody gives a
fuck. They're not drummers. All right.
Um, I think that's it. I think
that's going to be it for the podcast
as I'm fucking trying
to get a Gig in England.
I just fucking trashed everybody
over there. I'm just, you know,
everybody just fucking trashed
and American non fucking stop now.
And then you go to their countries
and you know, you see fat fucks,
you see losers. I don't know what
they're bragging about. I really don't.
They talk about how amazing their beer
is. I got to MIT, I went to Sweden,
they did as some good beers,
man. Couple of beers from uh,
actually had one from Czechoslovakia,
some checks,
some shit that doesn't even exist anymore.
The Czech Republic,
whatever the fuck it is.
I don't know.
That's another thing that
bugs me about Europeans.
They think they're so fucking worldly
cause they know all about Europe and shit
and it's like Europe is like
basically the size of half of America.
So if you know something about the state
next to you that's the same as like
somebody from England,
no one about France.
I mean he can fucking drive there at
this point. It's really not impressive,
but it is beautiful over there.
Whatever.
Hitler didn't bomb bomb and is
still left standing is very nice.
Um, all right. I was a little country
this week just cause I was tired. Uh,
blame it on that. Um,
and I think that's it.
I think that's all that I
have to say this week. Uh,
I just want to thank everybody
for the tremendous turnout,
the tremendous turnout in Philadelphia.
I actually had to stay an extra day
and add a show. That was awesome. Um,
let me hide my show's
coming up and a don't you?
English cons get all pissed off of what
the fuck I say because I don't even read
half the shit that you guys.
Right. You know, calling me up,
telling me if I talk
about American sports,
it's boring as if I give a flying fuck,
you know.
All right, let me get to my
website. He obviously I give a fuck.
I'm bringing it up.
Um, and I also, if you,
if you're just trying to
write shit to Piss me off,
it's going to work because I have to
respond to everything because I have that
disease where I have to make my point.
Um, all right, let's get to the, uh,
what I got coming up,
not this weekend.
Next weekend I'm going to be at
the Improv in Addison, Texas. Uh,
September 24th, 25th, 26th.
And I'm also the Sunday.
Is that the 27th?
I think I added the day cause I'm
hanging around going to the cowboys game.
Let me see here.
Uh,
checking out the calendar.
Yeah. And the 27th,
I'll be there Thursday through Sunday.
We added a Sunday show.
I'm going to be there. God Damn, it's to
bring your friends down and I'll see it,
the cowboy's game on Monday.
Then on, um, October 2nd,
third and fourth, I'm going to be at
the stress factory in New Brunswick,
New Jersey.
And uh,
the following weekend I'll be at the
Improv and Pittsburgh and all the rest of
my dates are up. My website. I
want to thank everybody for a,
all the great support. I've really had
a tremendous last couple of gigs here,
you know, going to Atlanta
over to Stockholm, Sweden,
and then down to Philadelphia.
Really tremendous turnout.
I really appreciate it.
And, uh, all you guys basically out there
asking me when I'm going to come to your
country, you know, Australia, New
Zealand, I'm working on that shit.
I'm going to try to put some,
uh, youtube videos up on a,
I discovered when I was in Stockholm,
Sweden, that youtube, you know,
there's like literally just like
Wikipedia, you know what I mean?
There's all kinds of different youtube.
So I just stuck with the English one
because I'm a fucking American surrounded
by people speaking English
and water. But, uh,
I'm gonna try to get some shit
up on maybe the Australian one,
the England English one or whatever.
I guess evidently that's a way
to build a following over there.
So hopefully I can travel over there
and maybe I'll check out some of your
sporting events and maybe I'll change
my opinions, but she knows something.
I would be way more open to enjoying
sports from England or someplace else.
If you could just tell me about them
without fucking trashing [inaudible],
you know, American sports first. If
you just want to hear me flip out,
then by all means, continue
what you're doing because
it's working. All right? But,
uh, you know, hey, no disrespect to
your troops that went over to Iraq too.
You know, I just wanna make sure I
didn't get a little out of hand there.
All right. This is all jokes, so don't
send me any fucking hate mail. All right.
That's the money Moni podcast for this
week. Thank you everybody for listening.
And, uh, I know there was one other
fucking thing I didn't get to.
Maybe I'll get to it next week.
That's it. That's it for the pot
cast. Everybody have a
great weekend. I'm fucking.